yo dude I want to do a science
show one of my goals is to make science
cool again I want to do a science show
get Bill NY Bill not cool whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa did you just say Bill NY
isn't cool not
cool this is going to be a worse post
for you than the swifties or the I like
him he's not cool disagree Bill Nye is
cool bill bill bill bill you're Bill NY
is cool what is that what do people
chant for when he walks down the street
yeah that's that's his that's in his the
bill n the science guy that's in his
theme song or Lally that that they go
they go Bill n the Science Guy and then
in the background you literally just go
bo b Bo but you're proving my point that
he's not cool that's the dumbest [__]
theme song mind he is the coolest
[__] Bill NY dude Neil grass
degrass Tyson cool Bill n the Science
Guy cool not cool stop it knowledgeable
stop it Bill n's cool Bill n how do you
define cool Bill
NY Bill NY is cool I don't care what you
or anybody says Bill NY if you see this
which I know you won't I rock with you
and I have been and me and all my homies
love Bill NY are you crazy Bill NY was
here before you follow Bill NY on
socials oh yeah you do Bill NY Bill NY
was here before Neil degrass Tyson was
Bill Nye Bill Nye was not pre Neil
degrass Tyson Bill Nye is my
generation's Neil degrass Tyson Neil
degrass Tyson is my generation's Neil
degrass Tyson that was dumb are you
telling me you think Neil degrass Tyson
came after Bill Nye are you saying to me
that you think Bill Nye not only is
cooler than Neil I don't even know if
I'm saying degrass right grass Tyson
you're right you think Bill NY not only
is cooler than bill you think he knows
more than Neil I think they know more
about different things isn't Neil
degrass Tyson more of a cosmos and a
universe guy he's always SCI he's
obviously a very knowledgeable guy Bill
n is more like he's more
into not the
cosmos are we so you're you're telling
me that bill nye's cooler than Neil the
grass eyes I never said that but I I but
you're the one who's saying Bill n the
Science Guy is not cool I don't think
cool is the word I would use to describe
cool is a word I would use for him but
you're clearly wrong I would probably
I'm going to go ahead and tell you right
now that a lot of people would disagree
on you because disagree with you on that
yeah oh oh I'm this is going to be the
first clip that I post from this podcast
and I can guarantee you people are going
to disagree with you and be like how do
you not find Bill Nye the science cat
cool yo dude I want to hear are you team
Bill NY or team Neil degrass Tyson who
do you think is gonna get more votes me
you think people like Bill Nye more than
Neil degrass Tyson does Neil degrass
Tyson have a theme song where they
scream his name and he doesn't have to
bill I didn't have to but he did bill
bill bill bill [__] so stupid [__]
love Bill let me see his page you I'm G
to is that his Instagram page he's old
as [__] now I'm not gonna lie but I love
Bill NY you actually do follow him of
course I follow Bill
ny's my god dude look at this dinosaur I
do love his bow ties yeah and I am a fan
of just I do like him I just don't think
cool is the right word well I don't I
guess your definition kind of cool might
be wrong then he he's like a sci he
plays frisbee yeah he does I love Bill
NY I I got nothing I'm because because
I'm G to tell you also why I like Bill
NY so much I can't tell you how many
times in Middle School in a science
class where we were like oh godamn the
font's so small on your phone you're old
Jesus but so I can't I can't tell you
how many times I've walked into a
science class and I've seen that old
little TV with a VHS tape popped up in
front of that classroom and every time
we'd walk in there everybody would be
stoked you know why cuz Bill and I was
coming on and we would have a grand old
[__] time you
crazy oh yeah hey man hey
man oh yeah hey man hey
man